こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです
みなさんがだーいすきなお菓子
これ、知っていますか？
たけのこの里
きのこの山
みなさん もちろん これの存在知ってると
思うんですけども
まあ ぶっちゃけ どっち派ですか？
僕は生まれてこの方ずっと
実は たけのこの里派だったんですけど
あの、大人になって
よーく考えたら
あれ？
（心の声：これ、きのこの方が）
（おいしいんじゃね？）
と思って それからなんかまあ
どっちでもいいやみたいに
正直 派閥がなくなって
あのー
平和軍になりました
まあ 正直な話 たけのこの方がおいしい
と思うんですよね 僕は
このクッキーがおいしいんですけども
僕 気になるのは なんと言ってもこれよ
このなんか、このわかる？
このよくわかんない周りの
手にとって食べると
この粉の部分が
めちゃくちゃ うぜえな！
それに対してきのこは
もうほら、ちゃんと持ち手が
しっかりあるから
手が汚れないんですよね
なんかパソコン触ってることが
多くなってきたんで
手が汚れるとちょっと
作業に支障がでるから
なんか きのこの山のほうが
好きになってきたのかな
っていう気はするんですけど
まあ正直なにが言いたいかというと
っていう気はしてまして
このパッケージも
めっちゃ似てるじゃないですか
そこそこのバカだったら
多分これ気づかないっすよ
ていうわけで きょうの企画は
またその逆も然り
どうですか、ぱっと見
もうパッケージはほぼ一緒
いや全然違うけど
違うけど似てるんすよね
正直中身が入れ替わってても
全然もう、全然 違和感がないわけですよ
今の状況だと きのこの山を開けると
たけのこの里が出てきても
ほら なんかそんなに
不自然じゃあないっすよね
たけのこの里を開けて
きのこの山が出てきて食べても
あーそんな気づかないよっていう
たぶん よっぽど意識してないと
気づかないと思うんですよ
今回、家にもうターゲットが
いるんですけども
まあ
こっそり
こっそり こう
たけのこの里をパッと渡して
ありがとって こうペリペリってやって
パリッとやって食べて
その食べたものが
たけのこの里の中身なのに
きのこでも
気づかないと思います
はい、ではやっていきましょう
裏から中身だけを出していきます
ここで壊すと元も子もねえからな
慎重にいかせてもらうぜ
【ｻﾞｯ(破れる音)】
まあ後で直すんで
オッケー出たー
おっけおけおけ…
俺なんちゅうしょうもないことやってんだ
後はのりでバレないように
しっかり固めていきます
これでしばらくくっつけます
一見しょうもない企画に
見えると思うんですけども
かなり高度な
脳内戦を繰り広げられる
企画になっております
「たけのこの里なんだ 」って
もう目にして目視的な意味で
分かるじゃないですか
ただ、開いた瞬間
たけのこの里という要素は
この画面に無いわけですよ
目の目視的な範囲ではね
開けた瞬間　しっかりたけのこの里
っていう意識が残っているんだったら
答えられるかもしれないですけども
開けた瞬間その
「チョコレートはお菓子だ」 っていう認識
たけのこの里だっていう認識が
チョコレートとかお菓子の
認識に変わった瞬間
今から食べようとしている
これがなんなのかっていう
固有名詞というものの
記憶が薄れちゃって
お腹すいてるとますます食べたい
っていう欲求だけになって
そのものの固有名詞とかを
忘れちゃうんで
開けた瞬間の情報量の少なさと
食べたいっていう食欲、意欲
本能的な部分に対して
どれだけターゲットは
たけのこの里がきのこの山っていう
区別的な意識が持てるかどうかが
今回のポイントになっております
まあ可能性としては本人が
とてつもない　たけのこの里信者か
きのこの里(?)信者だったら
すぐ違いが分かると思うんですけども
そこまでこの2つにこだわりがなかったら
間違えると思うんすよ
誰でも
意外と多分いけると思うので
早速、仕掛けていこうと思います
ではいこう
まさき：こっちにいたほうがいい？
はじめ：うん
ま：こっちでやんの？
は：こっちでできるはず
は：ん…どうぞ…
は＆ま：www
は：なに、ブームなの最近の？
ま：ううん
は：速攻、速攻で終わるよ、実際
は：実際秒で終わらしてやる
は：ふっww
は：あっそうだあれが、あげるンゴ
ま：www
は：まぁ…
は＆ま：www
は：ねえww
ま：ほんと、ありがとう
ま：ねえなに？
ま：撮ってる、今？
は：まだ撮ってない
は：ああ、後ほどね
ま：俺ち＿ぽって言ってて大丈夫？
は：大丈夫大丈夫、全然大丈夫
は：まさき　あれ、よく食べる？
ま：いや、たまに
は：もうちょっと
は：手伝ってもらうかもしれない
ま：えっ？
ま：これ…なに、えっ？
ま：ねえ！
は：えっ？
ま：www
は：よく…
は：気付いたね
ま：www
は＆ま：wwwww
ま：そこにあったの！
ま：こんな近くにあったの！